cher eric au nom du président de la
république et en vertu des pouvoirs qui
nous sont conférés nous vous faisons
chevalier de l'ordre national du mérite
une médaille pour un visage
incontournable du monde littéraire saint
quentinois et ricard d'un libraire de
profession a reçu jeudi sa médaille de
chevalier
je crois que depuis 30 ans que je fais
des activités syndicales c'était un des
points essentiels est important d'avoir
exercé des fonctions de président de
syndicat de la librairie française et
puis également président de la
fédération internationale des libraires
donc là il y avait une reconnaissance et
puis ensuite je pense également pour la
réussite des trois librairies pavés qui
ont quand même marqué ces deux lignes
nouvelles
sur les trois librairies deux sont
encore en activité
le pavé dans la mare à elancourt créé en
1975 et le pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux
fondée en 1989 eric ardent c'est aussi
un engagement syndical 14 ans au sein de
la fédération européenne des libraires
pour moi c'est vraiment le la récompense
de toute une carrière professionnelle je
pense que c'est amplement mérité et
j'étais très fier de pouvoir remettre
cette décoration est ré cardin qui
depuis 40 ans
est une voix qui compte dans la
librairie indépendante française est
quelqu'un qui a toujours innové
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais eu peur des
révolutions des évolutions de notre
métier et ricard d'un a pris sa retraite
en 2014 les pavés sont toujours là celui
du canal est aujourd'hui gérée par son
gendre
[Applaudissements]